by this power of castle hate skull i am
does helen mark harley
and you are my loyal viewers
i appreciate your fandom ship yeah
in case you were messing around doing a
reminiscing about uh
bruno borat bruno the entire
smorgasbord of comedy that we got from
ali g when you would see him on hbo oh
and it's sad that this generation
like that remember
yeah
and uh
oh i'm trying to find this one line
where he's like you know um
they're like at a sex round table and
one of the girls talks about watching
porn or something like that and goes
you know is it good for kids to be
watching poems
no of course not he goes well i've been
watching pornos since the age of 11.
you don't see me julie complaining now
masterful if you haven't seen that stuff
i mean
the showtime stuff that it does now
yes we're going to take the whole
episode to talk about ali
the showtime special that he does now
the the you know what is america or
whatever that was oh yeah it is really
good but it's so cringy
it's
painful to watch i feel like the alley g
stuff was a little bit less painful a
little bit easier
yeah the leg stuff has more like replay
value whereas when you watch the what
you know the
what's wrong with it yeah
yeah you watch it once you're like i
never can see that again yeah it's it's
but again it's i watched him going
goddamn he was in that scenario making
this person
you know run around with his pants down
or
just say some things where you look back
and you're like that must have been so
uncomfortable just to sit there and sit
with it
and donald trump famous he was the only
person to ever walk out of an interview
as he was pitching him um
i think it was popsicle gloves he's like
you know
when i eat an ice cream and it's
dripping on your fingers
you get ice cream gloves
boy oh boy i want to start out today
with a liver king meme of the week just
to start it off light tasty airy
i thought this liver king beam was
fantastic friend bro your crush is right
over there act natural
me picture of the liver king
that's amazing because like the joke is
he's not natural right
how do they come up with this stuff
then we have a liver king link right
here
liver king just wants to lift i saw him
doing this we get a little volume on
there he's in the middle of what looks
like a walmart
just lifting weights
this is the only place i feel at home
okay well if you could just understand
where i came from what i've been through
you know i'm just spreading a message so
many people are hurting in hatred i ask
you to stop videos we're just trying to
help people hey guys why do y'all like
litter kid
[Music]
there's a lot to unpack here because
he's in the middle of what appears to be
a walmart lifting weights the security
guard coming up to him it looks like
this is not the first time she's done
that today
now i got it to say he looks amazing
anywhere he goes it's a testament to his
physique that
he's just in some regular old walmart
lighting looking
fantastic
and
he's just grabbed some dumbbells and
he's curling with them and she okay
i don't know if those are his kids it
wouldn't surprise me there's some fans
but he's got this like row of fans that
he appeals to in the middle of the video
i have mixed feelings about this kind of
stuff and we'll talk more about stuff
like this later pranks in general or
going into the real world and filming
content where you're now putting
a paid employee in a position
to kick you out it's like you're getting
content at the expense of somebody
having to
do something that's yes it's a part of
their job but it's just not
who wants to kick somebody out and you
know that they're doing content or
whatever but you're sort of like
defying them
and pushing back against them doing
their job so in a way
i you know it's just not something i
would feel geared to do as much as i
maybe would do that as a kid or
something like that push back against
authority now i know something that's
that's something that casey does on the
weekends he likes to go into
random big box shopping
uh stores and
just
do things that are getting kicked out
like that's what he has for a rush in
his life you know
never did it um
so i don't know how do you feel about
that
casey delivery
i agree with you like
yeah who cares he's just lifting weights
in a walmart like also
that shouldn't be a thing like yeah
well why do you care if he's doing that
maybe he's testing out a product yeah
maybe he's testing out a product to use
it also don't do that we know that's not
what you're doing it's like both of them
just [ __ ] off right yeah it is funny huh
um
because like if how long can he do that
for how long is it a nuisance for what's
the problem with him doing it but also
don't do it right yeah yeah yeah
you're right you're right i'm curious
about all these questions it's like when
is it illegal because he has a shirt off
yeah why is it illegal to have your
shirt off in a you know a store or is
that just the policy are they going to
use physical violence they gave them a
shirt right yeah yeah what what is
what's going wrong what's going on here
what are the ethical boundaries here in
the walmart lifting these 15 pound
weights for our personal amusement
um also how dramatic he is of like where
i came from this and that while curling
like what do you i know he goes straight
he's so good at the character that he
just never turns it off it's really
something
to take notes on uh okay
we have another funny little video that
you know i could have put it in the this
is why we can't have nice james but i'm
gonna put it in bro science academy
because
it brings up another interesting
philosophical conundrum so this video
has been making the rounds on the
internet
and uh well let's just let it play the
focus is on this big guy over here big
guy older guy
all righty his posture is fine
once you get to the side you don't go
around asking people how many sets you
got left
yeah so we can pause it there uh just a
short clip basically we see this guy
who looks like he's in his 40s
he's more fat than he is buff he has
some muscle but um
the main takeaway from me that makes me
question whether or not he's i do
actually think he's serious here but
he's wearing neon green lifting gloves
and i've just never seen a serious
lifter who knows what the f they're
doing inside the gym as a man now i kind
of give
permission to female because you don't
want your hands all rough and callous
but it's just it's one of those running
things that um you know unlike something
for example where like we suddenly
decided that it was a meme to have uh
you know rollerblading is gay right like
bill bird is a great bit about this like
suddenly one guy yeah one guy's like
robert is gay and then you know everyone
has to stop doing it
uh there is something to this notion if
you're wearing lifting gloves as a guy i
kind of uh you know you go that's gay
that's whatever
this is how guys who wear lifting gloves
kiss their girlfriends and you know it's
the guy pinned up against a chain-link
fence with a girl holding his legs in
her arms
it rings true for me because i go first
of all i you i know you don't know how
to lift secondly you're not lifting hard
enough to even get calluses and as a guy
you want those calluses on your hands
you want rough masculine hands right so
i excuse women who who use that who
don't want rough calloused hands but
this guy's not only wearing gloves
they're big gloves and they're neon
green
and then he goes on to say
when you're as big as me like he's
obviously upset there's like either
police or security involved breaking
these two people up and uh you see that
it's a very young kid on one side and
this guy on the other side going
um
he's still upset about being asked how
many sets he has on a piece of equipment
and he references himself
he says
when you get to be this size right when
you get to be this big
you shouldn't be
asked you know how many sets you have on
a piece of equipment
which
even if he was ronnie coleman it
wouldn't have any bearing on somebody's
right to ask him how many sets he has on
a gym it is an innocuous question at the
end of the day it's hilarious to me
because i love delusional people in the
gym
but
this is something i used to struggle
with when people would ask me i would
get annoyed by it usually with the tone
people would ask because i felt like
people were putting pressure on me so i
would say something like i don't know or
a hundred or a thousand or a million
yeah mark's a dick oh my god he said he
had a million sets left on the like
press
now
because and some people
there is a tone where you kind of you
can
come across as pressuring
i always invite people to work in now
right that's my go-to and i think that
is just
the only ethical approach to this unless
it's totally impractical unless you're
like squatting five plates and this
person wants to do 95 you can't work in
but when it's just a machine with a pin
or something like that
i
this is a public gym in the sense that
um
you
you pay for membership and we all have
to share the equipment and the better
you can get along with everybody i just
think that
the gym is going to be better when you
have this attitude and i think that also
kind of goes along you don't really see
a lot of advanced lifters having these
shitty attitudes or being prima donnas i
rarely see that it's usually people who
don't know what they're doing in the gym
like this guy
that have these mistaken notions also
not only of just how to lift
but what gym etiquette is right of using
multiple machines my friend todd will
tell me
for example go into a
a gym and like a guy will be using like
three different benches and it's like
you can't do that you know you can't be
like oh i'm here but i'm also here and
i'm also here you have to allow people
to work in
um
but you easily see how people become
sort of like possessive it's this basic
human nature thing right this is mine
it's mine it's not yours right you're
using it for that moment that you're
doing it but we all have to share and it
just goes to show you
who was raised right who has siblings
whose parents didn't neglect them
whose parents uh
stuck around
didn't go get cigarettes and disappear
yes it is true
i have energy
i'm smooth
mentally not smooth-brained
but things are firing on all cylinders
i'm in a flow state how did i get there
well part of the equation is most
certainly kratom
and part of the equation of how i get
that kratom is most certainly
happyhipporples.com that's where i get
my happy hippo kratom from
and guess what thick boy studio is a
stock with it so whenever i want some i
just go out here and pop it but if you
don't have your own supply i urge you to
go to
happyhippos.com and use promo code
thick boy with three c's to get 20 off
of every single purchase you make for
the rest of your kratom using career
if you don't like it let me know but i
know that's not going to happen so
that's why i'm encouraging you to do
that
what i am encouraging you to do is order
some and then tell me what you like
about it because i guarantee you're
gonna like it
or your
podcast back
as you know by now
the promotion that i'm running for oak
and stone clothing whereas in the month
of august the remaining days if you make
a purchase broken stone
you will
get a free 20 minute plus consultation
with me because i say 20 minutes plus
when i get on the phone with people we
start jibber-jabbering i want to give
you that guaranteed minimum but who
knows it might be 40 minutes we might
get into a groove i might be driving
home and just
say you know
it's a 40 minute drive i don't need to
cut you off arbitrarily so take that
gamble
get these close
and you know what i do like them i wear
them in my real life and every single
person who's
actually
bought these clothes has something
positive to say both about the clothes
and the customer
experience
because again it's a small business and
the reason that i like to
promote this business and give you
insight into how it's run is because
there's not a lot of times where you get
a really cool clothing company that's
like
it's not a big corporation it's a small
operation and that to me means you can
have more care into the individual items
and into
the customer service experience because
you have a person who's dealing with you
making sure your experience of that
product is fantastic and everybody who's
ordered has
uh reached out to me in some way to
communicate that not one single person
has even been like no it's a little bit
not you know you have a
client of mine ordered some shirts and
had a difficulty
uh using the promo code
the owner of the business called him and
walked him through
uh using the promo code properly what
promo code was that
hella code hella get 10 off
use that and then send me
uh the screenshot of that or some sort
of proof of purchase and you can get
that consultation again
diet nutrition or anything if you just
want to talk to me
and if you purchase it you're like you
know what i don't want to talk to you
for 20 minutes let's do something else
i'm open to that too let's negotiate i
just want to give you something back for
getting in on the ground level of
oakenstone especially when you use code
hella especially when you shop at
oakenstoneclothing.com and not some
reseller
uh
don't get knock off oakenstone and don't
get scalped
oakenstone get the real deal from the
website
we're proud
i'm a big boy we just got some shirts
for crystallite we're going to see how
he likes them okay because i mean you
know get him before he once he wears
that and post it on on his ig it's going
to be over you won't be able to get
knocking stone shirts so get them while
they last let's go on to
hater of the week
sometimes this just happened to be last
night okay
this is the runner-up this week was a
guy from australia named underscore
barney w
he left not one but two comments what i
love about this
is he left a comment
and then he wanted to come back and back
that wasn't good you know i have more to
say right
i don't know how you find my profile who
cares
uh but you show up to my page and the
first thing he says is
what is wrong with your head
we're talking about the appearance or
what's going on inside it
[Music]
that's a self-slam
that's sort of opening the door to
questioning my own mental health in this
segment
so
what is wrong with i don't know what is
wrong with my head casey maybe you could
tell me you're right here it's huge it's
square it's dumb it's huge it's where
it's dominant
you know i'm glad you're laughing at
that i'm glad you think it's funny
so you're actually in this guy said you
know what
no actually podcast uh
confession i am underscore barney oh
i am barney the hate is coming from
inside the building
this guy
what is wrong with your head
what's funny about again anytime a guy
or a woman like imagine a girl coming up
to you and being like
hey your physical appearance is wrong in
some way right and like even just that
word wrong
okay sorry i don't have the right head
shape you know um
and i don't think that's even a common
thing to say but you know people
criticize me all the time for any one of
a number of things i like that he went
with head like do you mean my face do
you mean the shape of my head
can you be more specific with the hatred
so he says what's wrong with your head i
don't know what it maybe you could tell
me and then he goes you're a try hard
with lip fillers
and fake bro arms that's true
right because your arms
they are fake yeah and they are bro
right
this guy i also just love this person
took time they sat and typed something
they typed out two comments
and they have the entire
english language dictionary at the tip
of their fingers
and they choose words like fake bro arms
what does that mean does that mean i
take steroids to their fake does that
mean i have animatronic arms does that
mean
uh i photoshop these arms on
does it mean you know if your muscles
are big that means you have
fake arms i don't get it's so
non-specific i wish these guys would
just get better at insulting me because
it gives me more to work with i don't
even respond to this guy now i just post
him to my story
and then if we scroll down a little bit
i posted a picture of him with his
girlfriend then just zoomed in on his
face and said
yeah that makes sense
his d oh and also i also posted this i
didn't tag a minute so you can't see but
i went to his girlfriend's page and
requested her
damn player damn player
and i like that you know it's all just
it's not a direct response to either
your dms or your comments but i like to
play those games and just you know part
of me wants to send like this whole
exchange to her just to be like
hey dude's in the closet you know that
could be a benefit to her
to figure that out sooner rather than
later but uh
his retort to me just tagging him
because again that's
you know i have a weird head let me just
tag your head that's that's it what else
are you gonna do
no you he says good one big lips
at least spelled like an apartment lease
one word
a-t-l-e-a-s-e i'm happy
and don't have to fill my lips in to
hind my insecurities you knob
well in hindsight
you probably should have used spell
check
now
i like the assertion here that i'm happy
right
like yes i may be
spending my free time
criticizing the physical appearance of
other men but i'm really very happy you
see
this is obviously an indication of
how mentally well-off i am
i'm exuding happiness and confidence
obviously
at least i'm happy so that's it you know
i just like that was just like a little
runner-up that happened yesterday
that i'm going to share with you because
i still get stuff like this it's like
you want to be like dude that was so
2020 like get off these giant juicy lips
already find something else
okay the real winner though
of hater of the week this week
i'm going to tell you about ike catcher
now i'm going to do some content with
this later in the week can make a
shorter version of the story for
instagram but this thing happened while
i was at muscle beach um with isaiah
miranda we were shooting a video he
asked me to do
a video
where i would dress up as thor meaning i
would carry around a plastic hammer and
put on a red cape
and
people could challenge me to do push-ups
pull-ups or better we kind of figured it
out while we're there we're like oh what
are you going to do
these little youtube videos like i don't
come up with the stuff i'm not going to
be going to venice beach and getting a
camera crew and challenging people to
you know a competition of strength but
we end up at muscle beach i guess
because it's outdoors there's people
there there's tourists it's whatever the
vibe is right to do stuff like this
because you kind of
people can see you and then come in and
challenge you right
so we show up we get a few people
who you know recognize isaiah recognized
i mean recognize me the vibe was very
fun
you know somebody challenged me to do
push-ups
pull-ups body weight bench press we're
kind of figuring out on the go but i'm
being encouraging i'm doing like a funny
character like nobody can beat me i have
infinite strength but also you know when
they're going it's not like i'm going
boo you suck i'm like hey good job
trying to give this a fun vibe because i
believe in stuff like that i don't think
you have to be like hostile to people in
a youtube video because you don't want
them to get cash apt 50 bucks if they
beat me
uh in a push-up contest
now
there's this guy ike catcher
who
i had seen videos of before i've seen
some people put like a girl will post
him like
standing pressing her over her over his
head
he seems to be like this fixture at
muscle b honestly when i first saw him
i'm like is this like a homeless dude
who lives at muscle beach i really don't
know
but he kind of has this whatever a
gimmick where i saw i went to his page
all of his content was like
here's me doing muscle ups here's me
doing you know
handstand push-ups on the bars at venice
beach
not my thing i'm you know i see things
like that i'm like don't judge don't
judge don't judge but
would i personally you know hang out at
venice beach and work out all doors
outdoors all day for attention no but i
assume hey if i met him i'm sure he's a
nice guy
not necessarily the case you realize
that sometimes your assumptions about
people
are correct sometimes your intuition
can guide you so
while we were at
the shoot he shows up and i guess he
works at muscle beach or something
somebody's trying to tell me who knows
him
he either works or has a financial stake
either way
i'm going to outline what he did and why
his behavior was sort of shocking we
showed up we were in the middle of
shooting the video
he shows up and immediately starts like
pacing around
he looked visibly
upset
we're shooting a bit
and he comes up in the middle of us very
close to us on the bars and starts doing
muscle ups
but it wasn't like that was
him working out it was like very obvious
that he was doing this just to show off
and in fact he started grunting and
growling while while doing the muscle
ups like would do a muscle up and go
also the dude 69 has a great body like
this you know i
can compliment him honestly that he has
an amazing physique
and he's very tall good-looking guy so
you almost kind of assume like
this person is confident right this
person knows how to interact with other
humans right
again wrong
he starts after grunting and growling
going
this is my gym welcome to my home as
he's like you know going up and down
doing this
like yelling at whoever i'm not sure it
was really awkward because i'm like
standing there with isaiah like what is
he doing does he want to be part of the
video like i don't really know what's
going on
but i think the only right response was
oh my god you're so amazing do more
muscle ups do more handstand push-ups
you're so cool
i didn't give him that i sort of looked
his direction and wasn't sure what he
wanted to do he got off he shook hands
with isaiah ignored me did my eye
contact didn't introduce himself didn't
say a single word to me and kind of
went off to his uh the other side of the
gym again
we got a few more clips for the video
and then we walked off and as i'm
walking off
i looked back and saw that he kind of
was either facetiming
or filming me and isaiah
or in our general direction but it
looked like he was talking right so i'm
like hmm
i'm suspecting that he's doing some
video or story about us he didn't want
to talk to us while we're there but as
soon as we leave and we're walking away
and my back's turned to him
he starts recording me i didn't know but
i went home and checked the story and
found this so we got a three minute
little video
and uh so it says wannabe thor
challenging people to pull ups so i had
to show him some next level and you can
see me and isaiah i just hugged this
dude who did a pull-up competition with
me
gets in the bars
starts aggressively doing muscle ups
into handstand push-ups again i don't
think you can hear it but he starts
going welcome to my gym this is my home
this is my gym
you can hear it on isaiah's video um
pauses up there this is like a three
minute video so i'm not sure if all of
it's interesting but
because it would have been one thing if
it was just this right
he says how do i say and then he walks
off again
it would have been one thing if it was
just this but it's still rude it's like
oh wanna be thor first of all
i was in a movie playing thor so i
really am thor
then he goes and films the crowd i
assume this is meant to convey like
this crowd is all here for me look at
all these people here
which i think is a sign of his own
delusion then he starts
zeus came in and shut him down
this boy asked him if he could do a
muscle if he couldn't do one
all you four is he can't do one muscle
up boy
that's why i make him bow down that
muffle beats homie
so
he's doing this fake like
that's why i make him bow down a muscle
beach yeah though thor thought he was
doing something and i had to show him
what's up and he ran off like none of
that happened we got the clips you
wanted to and then we walked off like
normal humans
also he didn't ask me if i could do a
muscle up or challenge me to muscle ups
isaiah said something like
can how many muscle ups can you do and i
said none
because it's true i can't you know i've
never learned how to do one
would have been cool if i showed me how
to do it but i guess he was more
interested in talking [ __ ] about me
behind my back into a
instagram story so
it was this again that was like the
second thing where i go jesus christ
dude this guy's like you know in his
head i think that makes a lot of sense
that he's whatever
the king of muscle beach and
you know you can't come into
uh his domain without
him needing to prove his superiority at
doing muscle ups because i'm sure
there's other lips that we could do if
you if you wanted to have a legitimate
competition of strength let's deadlift
let's go out let's bench let's do
whatever olympic lifting
it's just you know
muscle ups are something there's some
more talking here that i want to get to
this part probably
probably what did he say
you come to my town
and bow down
we got some respect for the man that's
been flying this field for eight years
day in
know it's even though day
rain falling i was spitting on the
ground for the
trans pro
come out here
show some respect man you know what i
mean
all that competitive [ __ ] coming
into my little gym in my temple
you know what i mean
all these dudes
thinking
so because we got a little muscle
only
through this [ __ ] man
i don't care how big you are
flip where you want these bars and shut
you down
as simple as that
[Music]
oh my god it's amazing and then he plays
his own rap music uh you can look that
up don't worry about me i catch let me
know what you think of the comments of
ike catcher's music um
but it was interesting to see that
because he gave this extent he just kept
going with it right it was like wasn't
one clip or the next clip it's like
three four or five instagram stories
he's doing this monologue like
yo when you come to my town when you
come to my gym i'ma shut that down you
better show some respect in his mind i
do think that i wasn't showing enough
respect but i'm not sure how i would
have done that you know like at like i
use is i cure is the master of the
pull-up bars here can i come to pay my
respects like
am i supposed to offer gifts am i
supposed to uh you know
like
you know maybe he's just the permit guy
and you needed a permit to film there
and that's awesome
we actually did talk to the perma guy
before they were like yeah you can't
film like on certain times or on the
weekend there was some issue with it did
he say anything about filming when ike
was there oh right
well you can film oh here's what he said
you can film on an iphone but you can't
film on a camera it was like we paid and
we figured it out now
um so again when i look at that first of
all you know if you
are the permanent guy or you work for
the gym it's not a good look to
be discouraging people by being rude to
them right
so i would say the first thing you want
to do is not get angry that people
are not showing respect to you in your
gym like you know if i went to a
you know 24 hour fitness i don't go like
hey where's the manager let me pay my
respects to this guy before i go on the
stairmaster that's not how gyms work and
if you have a financial stake in it
um
you know it's not good business to be
like
mocking the customers that come and pay
for your gym because you feel they
didn't give you enough respect so
whether you're a worker you're there to
facilitate people working out and
following the rules which we did
and if you have a financial stake it's
also a bad look because
um you know
you're you're making yourself look like
a [ __ ] idiot on instagram right to
all of your followers and i think he's
got a hundred thousand followers you'd
have a million maybe if you
you know didn't act like a simpleton but
um
he posts that
and it just got me thinking about
the psychology behind that because i
think that surpasses for tough
or hard or
you know masculinity these days and that
term toxic masculinity gets thrown
around a lot but i would say that most
of it's illegitimate right what i would
consider a display like that as
is a sort of toxic toxic masculinity
because
it's a guy who's asserting
i'm tough and i'm the best
in a competition that
he's envisioning in his head right
if you're in competition with everybody
and that makes you
act hostile towards them but they don't
even know that you're in a competition
right and you're perceiving disrespect
when none is being given out that's an
ego issue
and you have a lack of
understanding of the reality of your
surroundings in the reality of your
place
within the real world and that's going
to always cause issues because
people with over-inflated egos or
fragile egos they see
threats where there are none and that
makes you act hostile it makes you
become paranoid and think that there's
plots against you you know i'm serious
about this like it's it's indicative of
a style of thinking that's very
non-constructive right
and
it's
again a sign of not toughness or
confidence that you would see somebody
filming a video and feel the need to
like
out do them in something
or show off in front of them even right
it tells me that
you were uncomfortable having two
seconds where the attention wasn't on
you
um you were uncomfortable with basic
social skills like introducing yourself
first if you're wondering what
somebody's doing you can go up and talk
to them right
if you're a guy and you're going to talk
[ __ ] about somebody
and mock them
and they were just there
you can do that to their face right
so
you know he strikes me as the kind of
guy who would try to fight me or
something like that like if i talk [ __ ]
about him like him now
but again you had that opportunity right
you had the opportunity to challenge me
directly you had the opportunity to
fight me or talk [ __ ] to my face
you chose to not make eye contact
let me walk away
make several videos
about me after the fact
and in your mind that equals
toughness or dominance and in my mind
that equals
insecurity
and fragility
and instability mentally right
and
i warn people young men specifically to
not go down that route of
seeing everything as a competition
seeing as every situation as i need to
assert dominance because you feel
threatened or even thinking of things as
yours is it your gym do you own the gym
okay again
like i said then
you're probably going to
you know have a better
outcome financially if you don't treat
people like that if you don't view it as
this is my gym
therefore i have to be stronger than
everyone in it and i don't think in
those terms i don't look into a gym and
go like i'm the strongest guy here i use
a hashtag buffisperson on instagram
because that's funny and ironic this guy
uses the
hashtag biggest man on the bars and it's
not ironic and i think that's part of
your identity and if you identify as
things like that like i am the best
always
what if you're not though
right
what if you're not what if uh what if
nobody cares about that right what if
what if what if that's the only thing
that you identify by and then anybody
posing any sort of threat or trying to
challenge you in any way that becomes
unhealthy because then it's an attack on
your identity not just something you can
do and i think any time you have
things like that that are arbitrary
wrapped up and this is me that isn't you
your height or your size your ability to
do pull-ups
isn't you and it just puts you in a
position where you're going to be more
hostile to everybody
because your identity is just that thing
expand your horizons
get a hobby outside of doing muscle ups
huh all right can we move on you know
i'm gonna do a more succinct version of
this story but i just had to get that
out there before i stop giving a [ __ ]
because i don't really care about the
stuff
or care to like get him back or make a
video about him you know go back to
muscle beach and do more muscle ups in
him
but
i'd have that happen to go this is
disturbing and weird and then you let it
go
after you talk about it on your podcast
okay you know what
let's get into the hello personality
portion of the podcast how much time do
we have left five minutes cool as much
as you want buddy
this was sweet validation for me
because
lex friedman interviewed a guy from his
uh from the cia actually the whole
interview was super interesting
but specifically oh because he talked
about
like for example different
branches of uh
uh like intelligence
divisions in different countries right
like what is the kgb like what is the
mossad like what is the intelligence
service in france like what are they
known for right like mossad i guess is
known for
having no boundaries whatsoever
to murdering people like
no and i think his phrasing was they'll
do anything
to
keep the israeli state alive and protect
its citizens so for example in
china we have people who have been in
chinese prisons for
30 plus years and america is
still looking for diplomatic solutions
and if it was israeli citizens over
there they would
conduct secret operations to go murder
everybody at that jail and take you know
the israeli citizen out of the prison
and nobody would know about it right
um for example and i guess france is
known for having the best technology but
they use it at a very limited scope
because
you know their their
operations aren't as broad as america
but everybody wants to collaborate with
the cia apparently we're the best in at
least some regards
as far as power
um
i'm relating this all back to the
myers-briggs personality test because a
lot of people give it [ __ ] i'll bring
that up and be like well isn't that
debunked isn't it like bad isn't it
worthless isn't it
uh
who's that guy who did
blink malcolm gladwell
he did a segment in his book essentially
saying that
the the binaries in mbti are all
arbitrary like extroversion introversion
sensing and intuition uh feeling
thinking judging perceiving
you could almost take anything you could
take four random things be like do you
like blue or red you know
uh do you have brown hair blonde you
could make like a 16 types out of four
different categories and it would like
divide the world up in a similar way and
be like oh yeah you're like a red blonde
blue guy you know
um
and that was hurtful to read because
i'm somebody who
lo it's like a hobby for me getting this
mbti stuff and it has helped me
legitimately
understand the world and so to see
people disparage on it um
to see people talk bad on it
it does hurt my feelings and it does
make me think
first of all stop second of all that's
mean third of all don't do that fourth
of all maybe you should reconsider your
position because lex friedman
youtube's greatest genius
has come out
with an interview now he could have
censored this because if lex even
brought up
these protestations to the myers-briggs
can we just play a little bit of this
yeah okay
because there's a special surprise it's
going to be a few minutes all right
let's let's let it slow roll do a
personality test
one for the hiring process but also for
understanding a human being this guy
used to be a c in the scientific is
extremely important for understanding
human being and i would say that there's
a thousand different ways of looking at
personality the only one that i count
with any with any significance is the
mbti
the mbti is what all the leading spy
agencies around the world use as well
boo yeah well that's kind of interesting
to hear oh yeah there's been criticisms
of that kind of test there have been
criticisms for a long time yeah and you
think there's value absolutely
absolutely and here's there's a few
reasons why right so first mbti makes
the claim that your core personality
doesn't change
over time
and that's how it's that's how it's
calibrated and one of the big arguments
is that people say that your personality
can change over time now what i in my
experience the mbti is exactly correct
you can your core personality does not
change because your core personality is
is defined as your personality when all
resources are removed
so essentially your emergency mode your
dire conditions that is your core
personality
we can all act a little more extroverted
we can all
you know be a little more empathetic
when we have tons of time and money and
patience
when you strip away all that time money
and patience how empathetic are you
how
how much do you like being around other
people how much do you like being alone
do you make judgments or do you do you
analyze information
that's what's so powerful about mbti is
it's talking about what people are like
when you strip away resources
should we keep going yes there's a
little bit longer i swear
i just don't know how much of somebody
else's youtube video okay well so i'll
say this much
um plus i'd like to just hear you
somehow right
now actually i can't that's a good point
i can i can sum it up from here um
there was a little bit of a surprise at
the end because he goes do you know what
your type is and he goes yes i'm an entp
oh my god it's me
um so it was cool to hear him talk about
that and how he's really into it and
validates it because i think like entps
are actually
sort of more likely to be into the
theory of personality you know because
like it's an abstract theory that helps
you
it almost like bridges the gap between
like humans and
machinery or something like that like
it's like an organized systems that i
can fit in human you know human beings
into um as bad as that sounds but
uh i liked a few things here
number one hearing that the intelligence
agencies around the world use that
because i'm like to me it's effective
and you can guess people and you can
analyze people it's actually practical
effective unlike say astrology unlike
say
i've heard enneagram stuff i've read it
this isn't it doesn't click into like a
system
you're such a leo
[Laughter]
what's funny is people can always guess
that i'm a leo maybe just because of my
hair it's like so i hate the fact that
like
yes you know
leo's i guess i give off
narcissistic leo vibes with my long hair
but you know so i'm like yes i'm a leo
but also you know
that's not why i'm like this
like yes i'm a middle child that's not
why i seek validation from others you
know that's why i'm not i'm not i'm
attention seeking for totally different
reasons
but
what he explains also is like this is
these personality things
are
stable over time these characteristics
and yes you can learn to be one way or
another when you have resources like
i've grown to be more empathetic by
practicing that and at some point
somebody kind of
instilled that that it's a value to
think about things from the perspective
of others and i've spent years
trying to activate that board and i
think a lot of men struggle with this
that sort of like knee-jerk empathy and
i think you can have too much empathy
right there's there's an ideal middle
for most
men in this world and some people
struggle with having too much i wouldn't
say i'm a natural empath but i've always
loved animals it's just
understanding the motives of people or
really feeling the things when it didn't
make sense to me i guess that's where
i'm coming from because if you're freak
you know if you're with somebody who's
like having a really strong emotion
to something that doesn't make sense to
you maybe your first instinct is like
that's stupid you're overreacting but if
you take the time to like walk yourself
into that person's shoes
and understand that different people
have different value systems right so
that's why i started to understand for
example that like an istj who's very
much about rules and procedure and we
should do this and follow the you know
the checklist
um like that it's their greatest
strength to sort of look at like a
manual or look at how things
traditionally have been done and
replicate that you need people like that
in many scenarios
i might butt heads with that person
because i'm proposing something more
unconventional and
if they don't like it the push back the
pushback might come across as like
you're wrong and i go well i'm just
giving options
but i understand now that in their brain
it's like
this gives me anxiety and emotional pain
to think of doing it the wrong way like
it's obviously like we should obviously
we should do it the right way and if you
can wrap your mind around the fact that
if you're not doing it the right way or
the way that they see fit it's not about
their ego it's about
the emotion that they feel the stress or
whatever and so i've learned to
depersonalize for example things like
that but everybody's different and if
you can get into their value system and
kind of the things that they lead with
um
i think you just have a lot more
patience for people you know and you
also have including for yourself because
i'm okay with like the things that i'm
bad at i want to work at it but it's
like
yeah like you know you can't it's harder
to make me feel like oh worthless person
because i'm not good at what somebody
else is good at
um
and he also talks about his wife being
an isfj who's like an inversion
of uh what he is he's exactly the
opposite right instead of extrovert
you're introvert you're a sensor not a
uh you know
intuitive
and i do think often romantic
relationships will have
like that inversion sometimes it'll be
like you'll the same as an s or an n
like you know an entp might work with an
infj
um or an estp could work with uh an isfj
like
so everything's different but that s or
n it's an interesting theory i don't
know i don't know how it turns out in
real life can you date somebody that's
you know i've met some hot girls that
are like entps and you realize like oh
you feel like my sister
we're still banging but it feels like
i'm banging my sister
so
i just i'm always fascinated by this
theory and it's interesting to see that
guy talk about it in the way that he did
and kind of see that
he's taking this risk by even talking
about these intelligence agencies and
the inner workings of the cia
but much like me i can tell that he's
leading with his love for information
and he wants to share that and so that's
less important for him than like
upholding the secrets of this
vaunted institution that's important and
he knows it's a risk but
he loves like
sharing that abstract and
you know unique information so much that
he's here on this and i've been grateful
for that okay can we move on already and
by the way lex friedman is an infj infj
is the rarest type um
according to the result this is a tweet
the infj is the rarest type and one i
share with carl young
dostoyevsky gandhi thomas jefferson
hitler sam harris and platinum oh my god
hitler is so terrible well if you're a
dark infj
you have
the greatest strength out of all the
types of intrapersonal
intelligence you know your own mind carl
young was able to analyze his own mind
and his own thoughts and often these
people are referred to as oracles and i
found that when talking with an infj
they seem to
be able to predict things not in the way
that an entp would any intp would look
for a pattern and be able to replicate
that or show you this is a pattern that
maybe other people can't see but if
forced to i could point it out an infj
will like go inside the web of their own
mind where everything that they've ever
experienced is interconnected
and
like they can predict things
in ways that could almost seem psychic
but what i refer to as is they're so in
tune with like the vibrations of the
universe it's like like a like you're
stepping on a spider's web almost like
past present or future something happens
and they're like this
little tiny step makes a big vibration
over here so it becomes more meaningful
that dream becomes more meaningful the
vision becomes more meaningful and they
kind of sound like crazy people but a
lot of times they're right and i know i
don't have that because i would be too
self-conscious to be like i had a dream
about you casey and this gonna happen
but you know an infj will be like no
it's gonna happen
then it happens
and then you murder that infj
don't do that no don't do it no don't
hey guys let's preserve these infjs okay
come on no murdering okay can we get to
the hou you know i put you through all
that that was just a test are you still
here
[Laughter]
this was the objective was
let me see if i can make the most boring
podcast
that i've ever put out
but then reward you with the best list
of gym fails that you've ever seen this
is why we can't have nice gems you know
first of all this girl is trying to
clown this dude this [ __ ] really
brought his own bar to the gym what's
wrong with that well maybe that you put
it in you know into a honda civic but uh
and also that you're bringing it to and
then bringing it back but that's to me
that's normal because bar there is a
difference between bars if you can grip
something that's a little bit small
these deadlift bars have whip and they
have like they're a little bit smaller
than diameter that makes a huge
difference because you can only lift
what you can grip onto
and also if something has whip in it
whip
the middle part is going to lift off so
it's almost like you're dead lifting a
lighter weight if there's a slight bend
in the bar
that first plate will get up and then
you're a little bit higher and then the
other weights start to get off so if
it's a super stiff bar it makes it
harder too for example deadlift and you
don't want that on a
squat you know you don't going
everywhere but on a deadlift sure so i
get it i'm team bring your own bar
don't be self-conscious kings i like
this one it said uh you have a the
girl's like oh the guy's going hey can
you put another 10 on the side of the
bar and then it's her
she's a 10 out of 10 very attractive
the reason this is a gym fail is because
she's actually a nine
and i just want to point that out just
kidding she's really cute and you know
what i like those little creativity i've
never seen anything like this before i
this trend in
instagram fitness whatever people do the
same joke over and over again like
they'll literally just recreate a sketch
and i'm just like have you no shame
people
so at least this was original
and it was all yellow this dude is doing
this a classic just gym figures what are
you doing bro you rolled up to the la
fitness
in tight jeans
put on a lifting belt over your
sweatshirt and loaded a bar up with four
35 pound plates which should be illegal
okay
green ones i'm okay with yellow ones i'm
not okay with who the [ __ ] ever does
that
we need to put an end to this do not
stack yellow plates
one
to the next and
i'm just gonna do the math real quick
that's uh 140 pounds each size that's uh
280
then 45. it's about 325. now of course
this form sucked and of course
everything about that was wrong and it's
no surprise when you see somebody with a
belt over their sweatshirt and jeans
guess what their squat form form's gonna
look like right it's just you're never
gonna see it you know when you see the
lifting gloves you're like and guess how
he lifts because he doesn't care about
anything else you don't care about doing
it right why can't we learn how to squat
this is gonna be a squat series right
here
uh-huh oh
now
this may come across as racist but why
do we only see black guys do this
if there's a video of a white guy doing
this in any gym
send it in i want to see it because to
my knowledge i've only seen black guys
do this sort of like
explosive push-up dancing on the gym
floor where you're like crawling like
you throw yourself down on the ground
and then you like go to your elbows and
then your wrists and you pop up and like
do this exploding starbursts in the air
and come back
it's both impressive and highly
embarrassing
much like most of my life
you're like mark you're not that
impressive
but i'll tell you what it is
so
these are fake bro arms right you know
which i
i didn't think of that but yes if you're
going to call me fake bro arms while
this guy's still alive and ticking
you're just wrong because
now certain parts of the world notably
russia and brazil this seems to be much
more common because
nobody would do that in america and also
we have access to healthcare
and your doctor would be like what the
[ __ ] are you doing
this so these guys if you don't know now
synthol
is an oil that bodybuilders actually
inject you've probably seen many
bodybuilders on stage you wouldn't know
it though because they use it more
judiciously
judicial system
they
use a site enhancement oil they'll
inject many ccs
of just this regular oil that in theory
dissolves into your body over time but
none of it's good because it can cause
necrosis it can cause nerve damage it's
just not good to inject yourself so much
right like even doing a weekly injection
over time you're going to have scar
tissue and it's not that great for you
oil can cause inflammation in the
muscles like ideally
you wouldn't experience some of these
things but it's pretty low level if
you're injecting liters of oil
and it's also
not synthol i guarantee it it's either
olive oil or motor oil or something
crazy like that guy we saw in um t-fat k
the king of the oil guys from india just
died it's not healthy like i mean you
know if if a cc of oil can cause
inflammation imagine what this is doing
but also does this guy have friends like
nobody's going hey but don't do that
right but don't inject
your arms with so much oil that they
look like actual beach balls
and then you don't know how to lift
still of course why are we shocked he
doesn't know how to lift he can't even
do a lat pull down which is the easiest
of the pull downs
tom platts dude
if you guys don't know this he's the
he's known for his legs
you can do leg
presses but why best legs of all time
maybe why do it inferior
movement why do a movement that looks
good that produces
look at the disgust on his face he's
like
very expressive it's almost like you
know like a robot face that's like doing
leg press is bad
i mean there's a reason people don't
squat
there's this video of him doing
i believe it's five plates it could be
more it could be up to like 525 but
something like it's 500 pounds probably
a little bit more and he does it like 24
times astro grass like and somebody like
a power lifter like goes right before
him like a big ass dude and he gets it
like
you know nine times and he kind of like
goes to parallel and he goes like high
bar asta grass
like
boom boom like 24 times in a row and the
dude's not that big um but maybe best
legs of all time and i do i like what
he's saying like you should learn you
know yes tom platts
uh
insane dude
now i look at that and go why would you
want leg zap like it is impressive but
it's like
you know
it's a lot to carry around right but
incredible lugs and when you see videos
and training legs you're like oh yeah
that's that's how you build legs like
that just all these drop sets on leg
extensions
what the [ __ ]
it's
right no it's insane
they're insane right um
but again
commensurate with the work he put into
them and that's the thing is like
one of the reasons i'm proud of you know
having more muscular legs is
because
it's not easy to work them you know i'm
still sore from saturday from an eight
just eight sets of leg press
and only a few cents to figure out
saying that they tried it
um world record uh yeah there there it
is 23 reps at
5 25. okay so it wasn't too off
but this 525 i've never even squatted
that much once and look how far down he
goes on each rep
[Music]
just absolutely sitting down
and you think he's going to stop and
that's like
yeah
and 24
but tremendous right and there is
something to that where it's like we
watch all these videos today
all these guys not knowing how to squat
or not knowing how to lift properly and
like it's you know it's it's the reason
you don't see a lot of people squatting
properly is because it's tough it
doesn't feel good
and um
if you're gonna like but it's like
picasso
you know don't be a cubist before you
can be a realist i've always said that
right
this is not an original thought by me
for sure but like i've always thought
about that like it's a great analogy for
anything where it's like
if you're doing leg press because you
don't know how to squat like learn how
to squat i get what you're saying you
know um yeah like you can't just be
these abstract painters like and even
boss i know boss gap people love him but
i don't know if he was a talented artist
as far as realism and so the reason i
think picasso gets the credit that he
deserves is he was a mass you could you
know paint or draw something to look
exactly like it did in real life
and then he was like actually you know
i'm gonna draw a cow that looks like it
was sliced
and rearranged and flattened out you
know then we're like okay cool
you're a genius master the fundamentals
yes exactly massive and then get weird
but like don't get weird and that's
probably the running theme of this whole
show is like you know these fake gurus
who are like no no no the fundamentals
suck do this weird stuff that doesn't
work
and i've never progressively overloaded
anyone on and i take nfl athletes and
make them do this and then make you
believe that they got to be nfl athletes
by doing this
okay i know we have like 30 more videos
why you never skip like they do no this
video's in reverse mark no i'm a video
editor dude i could tell by how do you
know because the clouds moving backwards
the dynamic movement of his shirt is
going on
wow he went to the shirt dude good call
but again i think it's something to keep
in mind because we're just watching tom
platts like tom platts is famously able
to jump on the top of slides very easily
just like this guy
so once again never skip leap day
now
um this this one after this is funny
yeah because i think they're doing a
prank like either it's planned or not
but he's like i'm going to squat you
just in your butt cheeks and then you
actually just bring it up and then he
goes and it's like all right dude like
yeah get the bar off my back and then he
just flattens himself
and honestly that's what you get
you know
part of stuff like this where i look at
this and i just it's funny but
i know personally like i've never done
pranks in the gym like that i'm like oh
let's like let's joke around with 300
pounds on my back like i do sketches in
the gym but this type of stuff but
honestly it kind of pisses me off more
so than like i have lower tolerance for
silliness in the gym than i do for
almost any other area of my life like i
take it personal and i'm not mad at that
because
[ __ ] like that happens where it's like
you can get seriously why are you
playing around with 300 pounds on your
back and now your knees
don't do it
an emotional appeal from mark harley
stop i like this guy
skyler uh
skyler's coach you walk into the gym can
i please get a spot and it's just
[ __ ] 350 pounds of dude
look at the crossfitter going nuts and
the bands
got what looks to be
i don't think it's ronnie coleman but
he's twerking on stage
and then this
fat pierced up power lifter all right
good enough and i think it's accurate
this while we can't have nice pranks
this is really long oh [ __ ]
how y'all doing today how long have i
been together
um
do you trust each other 100
oh yeah
maybe we test that theory yeah
swap phones
go with that would you kc yeah yes
you're like yeah
once they ask then your position you
can't be like no
so she's going oh who's trevor that's a
streak
awkward silence
he's trying to come see you know what
you're doing tonight
before that she goes huh
you know when you get caught and you're
like huh what huh what'd you say
i see
[Music]
and they solve racism
how about that huh
to me that looks real
like the awkwardness of everything i
don't know like he was underplaying it
it could be fake but to me it looked
real i think people do stuff like that
these little prank videos we're not
pranks it's like hey let's let's do a
social experiment let's get see people
can swap phones
her nervousness is really what sold me
on it could you pick up on that yeah
definitely but she's like huh like
trevor
but once you go
once you take that step into like sure
i'll do this be like nope wait a second
but what i would do is i would just take
my phone and just like throw it in the
pond you know or the nearest like just
like they're like oops and they'd be
like muscle spasm yeah
i stomped on my own phone
to get out of any sort of incrimination
uh-huh this one you can't have nice
trampolines see i made at least one of
them makes case casey laughs i'm good
this happened to me you know not the
exact same thing but i love how
this fella there she's not injured but
it's like it's a traumatizing event and
you kind of realize like trampolines are
super dangerous oh yeah right we're just
like jumping we're like hey jump up and
down you get 20 feet in the air but also
there's holes everywhere that are like
this perfect size to put a baby or your
leg in there i remember doing a backflip
on one and as i'm coming down like you
know i'm in the middle and i i'm
flipping in the air and coming down and
i realized my leg was going to land in
one of those holes and in that split
second you're like my leg's about to
snap in half like you can picture what
what's happening
now
my
leg went down here and then it like i
like hung off
you know but it bent at my kneecap
but like you know you're like nah it's
so traumatic like you almost think you
broke your leg you know you're like
obviously i'm hanging off of this thing
it's broken we had uh
you know there's four brothers in my
family yeah
uh they were all gymnasts my dad was a
gym teacher we had a trampoline in the
backyard but it was like the old school
like 80s one where you dug a hole in the
ground oh yeah it was flat with the
ground that's better yeah way better and
then around that you just have
gymnastics mats
so because you actually know how to do i
mean that's so funny because it's like
oh
you can take away all the danger of it
when you see like actual gyms yeah they
have like the spotter there with the
thing and it's like yeah because [ __ ]
happens but then we would add danger to
it because it was right next to the shed
yeah we would go from the shed to the
[ __ ] to a mini [ __ ] to the above
ground pool nice wow yeah dude yeah that
is freaking wild then your dad was all
okay with that would you do it under
okay with it was his
idea but i also think that's cool
because it's like your dad's going hey
we can do this dangerous stuff but like
let's do it the right way yeah you know
and then let's have a couple drinks
first right hop on the shed
let's get drunk and do a double
trampoline
and here's fine we're gonna end it off
with a sketch debut here
after we do this okay this is why we
can't have nice parks no i like this
because what are you thinking again
was he gonna land on this it's like hey
let me just do a backflip and place my
groin to the nearest uh sharp object the
nearest phallic symbol
in the park
you're just asking
you're asking for trouble you're asking
to never breed again once you get your
balls smashed on that scooter i'm afraid
to keep scrolling down what is it
don't don't be afraid
do a slow sensual scroll
okay he's wearing pants all right yeah
you want me to play on this one of these
days though yeah
a lot of people have been asking me mark
we see that you work chest every single
day why is it so important to work your
pack seven days a week well the answer
is your pec supports you in a plank
which is crucial to supporting your body
in a missionary position so just
remember kids you can't have great sex
unless you have great pets more tidbits
from mark coming soon so just remember
that you can't have great sex unless you
have great pecs and that's all you need
to know
it's chest day but it's also sex day
right so boom again you just it's
non-functional how much do you have to
do this no you have to do that in real
life right when you're banging dude when
you're having intercourses with the
woman's okay
this you know if you can't support
yourself like that we're just going to
lay on her the whole time you know you
don't want to be the guy who's like oh
hold on i'm cramping up like
dude
she's never going to come back to your
house again you want to be like what
this is super easy dude
like and then you also want to pump too
so like looks like you're like what i
didn't really know they're all they
always look like this
i just make them do all the work
and that's why casey's a misogynist and
he hates women worse than andrew tate
thank you so much for joining me today
guys we're just gonna end on that note
we finally figured it out casey massages
he hates women and i'm a good guy okay
even a lot of people will say like oh my
god i'm
you know i i have fake bro arms yeah do
these look really fake huh do they do
they
i think so okay yeah kind of like 10
fake like i mean more like unbelievable
you know it's like oh my god they're so
huge and ripped like it's crazy could
this be no they are real dude come feel
them in person and remember
buy oak and stone
you